and tonight the Academy is proud to
present the Gordon East Sawyer award
- Jonathan Ireland
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
hi
first let me say how astonished but
deeply grateful I am to the site tech
awards committee their chair Ruffini the
Board of Governors president John Bailey
for this recognition and of course none
of this would have been possible without
the love and support of the woman I love
my wife Kay
and indeed my whole family I don't think
I could have known 34 years ago and I
joined this institution just how
significant it would become in my life
early on I hold up in our library where
I library our librarian Linda Mayer
who's with us this evening provided me
with the trove of materials on the
history of our institution it was a
revelation it may come as a shock to
some here this evening to realize that
we are not created to put on a
television show even the very idea of
awards was not a given an early Board of
Governors agenda contained the following
discussion item when if at all should we
address the issue of awards our Academy
had far more pressing matters to
confront dominating those matters was
the science of cinema so much so that
our second president William DeMille
presiding over a general meeting was
moved to respond to complaints about the
emphasis of science over art by saying
if we don't get the science first there
ain't gonna be no out
the twenties of the last century were
indeed a time of great turmoil for the
art science of cinema fledgling Academy
waded into the chaos and in short order
sorted out the basic raw material which
made movies possible light itself by
managing the transition from mercury to
tungsten then it followed that by
reducing the babble of disparate early
sound systems to a functional one and
even conducted a school to teach it my
study of our history was transformative
for me and the Academy mission
increasingly became my mission a lot
happened in the succeeding century and
our art science has gone through many
changes but were actually in much the
same state of chaos today as ever and
dimille's admonishment is a zap today as
it ever was
the salient point is that our Academy
was created to make art possible to make
the excellence of the art science of
cinema possible in turn cinema can and
does help make the world a better place
and us better people in it our Academy
can take great pride in its contribution
however in the middle of the last
century we became complicit in the
blacklist damaging people's lives and
tarnishing our reputation so I hope
today we can stay focused on fostering
the pursuit of excellence of cinema and
let cinema itself be the agent of change
in our society
a quick glance at the recipients over
the last decade refutes this award is
thought of by some as a career Kappa a
quick glance of the recipients of the
last decade refutes that perception my
friends and colleagues here Gary Dimas
Ruffini ed catmull Peter Anderson and of
course Doug Trumbull all remained very
much still in the game and in spite of
being passed my sell by date I intend to
work until I drop the recent decades of
my life were dominated by work that I
did with colleagues and staff on the
SciTech Council especially dan Sherlock
until Joe de Gennaro and Scott Dyer
concerned with such issues basic to the
cinema process as light and time light
in the form of the quality of light
produced by the newest instruments
including solid-state LEDs and time in
the form of frame rates and the various
techniques by which the cinematographer
becomes the master of time itself since
I termed out of the council Kay and I
formed the Pickfair Institute for
cinematic studies where we continue the
work of expanding the cinema palette in
this we collaborate with many colleagues
including Rajesh Ramachandran of cube
cinema Bill Schulz of photo cameras CO
and Doug Trumbull with whom I feel an
almost fraternal relationship because we
were both blessed with the experience of
being mentored by his father Dom
Trumbull as were more than a few of the
early Star Wars filmmakers we hope also
to collaborate with the Academy as we do
with the digital projection of silent
films project the future bristles with
technological challenges such as virtual
reality which the Academy is guardian of
our past and guarantor of our future
recently acknowledged soon we'll have
self-illuminating screens and the
prospect of orders of magnitude greater
dynamic range in both image acquisition
and display the Academy's role
as midwife in the adoption of new
technology is needed as much as ever
I might have dreamed of this day when I
I began a career as an actor more than
60 years ago indeed both Dame Judi Dench
and Vanessa Redgrave who were students
with me at the Royal Central School have
been thus honored but I certainly never
dreamed I'd get here quite this way 40
years ago a film I worked on won an
Oscar for visual effects one of the
recipients of that first Star Wars Oscar
was the late Grant MacEwan the grant the
incredibly gracious grant loaned that
Oscar to everyone on his team to keep it
home for a week that was as close as I
ever thought I would come to this
reflecting for a moment on that original
Star Wars film this brings the
cumulative total of Oscars to at least
32 that's just for the visual effects
team a tribute to John Dijkstra's
ability to pick talent over time my
career path swerved from in front of the
camera to behind the camera there were
at least some there were some rationale
for this in that I also studied film at
the London Film School but if you think
there's a significant difference between
the science side of cinema and the
artistic side let me hasten to assert
there really is none or at least not as
much as you might think in cinema art
and science are bonded together and at a
fundamental level revelatory and as such
enlightening the same Faculty's
imagination invention insight keen
observation and a talent for
problem-solving are the essential
ingredients of performance in either
case reviewing the list of my fellow
sawyer awardees i find that they've been
just 26 of us it's an extraordinarily
select group
moreover I find that I've known 3/4 of
them many very well and some like Lyndon
Don Rogers Petrov Lajos EDA Giulio rod
Ryan and tack Miyagi Shima I count as my
mentors and exemplars it's a small
community stretching back for half my
life scarcely a dozen of us still living
reminding me that our Academy is not an
edifice that we have one and a very fine
one at that nor is it an award show that
we have that too and the wonderful
extravaganza it is an Academy is by
definition a body of academicians that's
flesh-and-blood people now more than
7,000 of us an eclectic community of
various perspectives but imbued with a
shared belief ethos and mission to
foster the pursuit of excellence in the
art science that is cinema to cherish to
cherish
to cherish and defend that out science
from rampant commoditization against
incredible odds because as entertaining
as we may be and we do they're
wonderfully well as well
the ultimate goal and purpose of art is
enlightenment
indeed this country and this art science
both sprang from the Age of
Enlightenment and enlightenment is not a
commodity
[Music]
now I need to beg your indulgence for
just a couple of minutes longer for a
coder a postscript our early academy
accomplished a great deal because our
forebears really were the Academy there
was then essentially no administration
or staff there were instead committees
many of them and they collectively
transformed early cinema over time a
growing administration comprised of
non-members displaced academicians in
many functions and operations of the
institution the Academy became
increasingly award centric and members
largely relegated to a novo and Award
voting panel a mere appendage of the
Academy however this community is
comprised of much of the best
practitioners in the field of cinema to
waste the awesome awesome potential of
the resource is unconscionable if we are
to fulfill the dream that Fairbanks
Pickford and the other founders had for
our art form we must collectively
reassume more responsibility for our
institution presently we cannot even
know who our fellows are much less do we
ever meet with them my own branch has
managed just one meeting in recent years
no two branches have held a joint
meeting in decades so at this point I'm
going to turn the podium over to Mary
Pickford's voice so she can make her own
case the Academy is the League of
Nations of the motion picture industry
it is our open forum where all branches
can meet and discuss constructive
solutions to problems with which each is
confronted in in the past we were never
able to get together on a common ground
and in making this possible the Academy
has provided has been
a great service the producer star
featured players cinematography
every individual can come into the
Academy with any problem or proposal and
feel that all barriers are leveled that
in this open court
his voice carries the same weight as
that of any other person regardless of
position and standing there is no
greater force for coordination no
greater Avenue for constructive and
intelligent cooperation for advancement
than that offered by the Academy of
Motion Picture Arts and Sciences thank
you
Thank You Mary and of course my thanks
to the Academy
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and there we are congratulations to
Jonathan and congratulations to all the
awardees at tonight's ceremony and to
everyone who works so extraordinarily
creatively in this industry while I was
listening to Jonathan it occurred to me
that another Englishman wrote something
once which is perhaps appropriate for
this event he didn't know it would be of
course because he lived 400 years ago
but he wrote a little prologue at the
end of A Midsummer Night's Dream if we
shadows have offended think but this and
all is mended that you have but
slumber'd here while these visions did
appear
and this weak and idle theme no more
yielding but a dream gentles do not
reprehend
if you pardon we will mend and as I am
an honest puck if I have unlearned luck
now to scape the Serpent's tongue we
will make amends ere long give me your
hands if we be friends and Robin shall
restore amends thank you good night
[Applause]
[Music]